[Music]
hello everyone welcome to a special
edition of ml news we have something to
discuss open ai just released an
embeddings endpoint to their api this is
accompanied by a blog post called
introducing text and code embeddings in
the open ai api now after the let's call
them big successes of gpt-3 and codecs
which is the model that powers github's
co-pilot openai pushes forward into the
domain of embeddings hold on this video
is sponsored by weights and biases
weights and biases is your one-stop shop
for all your machine learning needs it
will track your experiments with a
single line of code they'll upload
automatically all your logs all your
configurations everything to your cloud
it will automatically grab all the
output all the metrics all the
configurations of your experiments and
store that in one neat location so you
can see your experiments you can track
them wherever they run you can compare
among the experiments but you can go
further you can then tune your hyper
parameters according to the results of
those experiments and all of this is
done automatically in a distributed way
you can literally sit on your toilet on
your smartphone and tune your
hyperparameters and start new
experiments but it's not only experiment
tracking and hyperparameter tuning
weights and biases has tools for the
entire pipeline of machine learning
research from the initial idea up until
the deployment and beyond that when you
actually want to track what you've
deployed weights and biases has cool
methods to track all of your data set
and their dependencies to each other as
well as your models and all kinds of
other artifacts that you might produce
they're very powerful visualizations for
all the inputs and outputs of your
pipelines as well as the models
themselves all of this runs in the cloud
but if you're concerned about privacy
there are options to self-host the
system is free for personal use and for
academics and they have great plans for
enterprises small teams large teams
doesn't matter so thank you very much
weights and biases for sponsoring this
video if you don't know them yet
absolutely check them out it's free
it'll make your life a whole lot easier
now let's get into the video
[Music]
so briefly said an embedding model
associates a piece of text with a fixed
sized vector the fixed sized vector can
then be used to do semantic similarity
search in high dimensional spaces among
other things they have a toy depiction
of these uh embeddings right here now as
this clearly shows furries and football
fans are in fact linearly separable so
you know thanks openai in order to get
these embeddings you'd interact with the
openai api as you would else you'd
instantiate it you call it you get back
a vector they have three different modes
available one is for text similarity
which essentially means that you can put
in pieces of text and if the vectors are
close together that means the texts are
in some way similar the second one is
for text search where they have a
separate encoder for documents which are
i guess longer pieces of content and
queries which are shorter pieces of
content and the idea is that you would
rank document vectors against a query
vector and then whichever ones fall
closest together those would be the
relevant documents to retrieve for that
query it's a bit similar to text
similarity the differences are in the
length of the things that you put into
the models and also a little bit of the
semantics although i don't think there's
too much of a difference the last one is
code search which is essentially the
same as text search for code what's also
to be said is that these come in
different sizes ada being the smallest
and da vinci being the largest da vinci
is the original 175 billion parameter
gpt3 model size they do release a paper
along with it on how they train this
thing and what the results are and the
brief summary is that in various data
sets in various tasks they do beat
previous state of the art results for
example in linear probe classification
which is where you take embeddings and
then you train just a small linear layer
on top with a labeled dataset they
outperform previous state-of-the-art
they also do so in text search tasks in
the buyer retrieval benchmark and lastly
they outperform on code search quite a
bit the paper goes into more details on
how the model was trained they explained
that it is a contrastive loss that
they've used essentially what you want
to do is you want to encode pieces of
text through the encoder and then make
similar things closer to each other and
negatives uh in this case in-batch
negatives further apart from each other
this does require quite large batch
sizes to actually get an accurate
distribution of negatives but you know
it's a open ai so they can do it as i
said their models go from 300 million
parameters for the smallest to 175
billion for the largest with the
embedding dimensions going from 1024 up
to a ridiculous 12 288.
now you might think the larger dimension
is a good thing but this is not
necessarily the case right here this is
one of the criticisms that's going to
come up in a short while you can also
see right here that yeah indeed the
batch size is pretty large the paper
itself goes into a little bit more
detail into the results and here we kind
of see the first scratches in what
people are now saying about this model
namely that
it doesn't seem to perform that well now
while these average results that they
have presented uh mostly from their
extra-large models do outperform other
things is very often that they don't
outperform them by that much and if you
actually look in selected tasks then
it's not even clear they're the best
model also they seem to compare
sometimes to quite outdated baselines as
you can see these papers are sometimes
from 2021 and uh last i checked it's
2022 so
you know open ai get your crap in order
now by far the biggest controversial
point right here is the price as they
say in their documentation encoding 1
000 tokens with a da vinci model will
cost you 60 cents now 60 cents doesn't
sound like a lot but corpora often have
a lot more than a thousand tokens
remember that tokens are
not even words they're kind of sub words
and that means that this model is quite
expensive now this gets drastically
cheaper if you go down to the smaller
models as you can see the curie
embeddings are already 10 times smaller
and babbage and add another factor of 8
or so so pretty shortly this twitter
thread here blew up by niels reimers who
says gpt3 embeddings by openai was
announced this week i was excited and
tested them on 20 data sets sadly they
are worse than open models that are 1
000 times smaller and running open air
models can be at 1 million times more
expensive this is accompanied by a
medium post called open air gpt3 text
embeddings really a new state of the art
in dense text embeddings where he
leverages a lot of these points that
i've said previously like
they seem to not compare to the most
recent and most performing bass lines
and their results don't seem to be that
far ahead of the competition especially
if you consider the smaller models and
also that they did weird selections of
data sets that they've trained on for
example the buyer benchmark has 18 data
sets and they have chosen to just test
on 11 of them and report average
performance across those 11. so niels
assembled his own benchmark of tasks and
tested these models against some openly
available models and the most shocking
conclusion is that it seems to be that
for some tasks at least you can get much
better performance with the open models
at astonishingly low cost as you can see
in this table here this lists
performance against the cost of encoding
1 million documents which even for the
smallest openai model costs 800
goes up to 60 thousand dollars for the
largest one and on the open models well
the most expensive tested right here
will cost you six dollars and eighty
cents and the best performing one two
dollars and forty cents now it is to be
said that these prices are probably made
such that the largest possible shock
effect is achieved very often when he
mentions prices he says that well this
is the cost of like a preemptable t4 or
gpu which i guess first of all you get
the difficulty of being preemptable
which you don't get with open ai and
second of all good luck finding quota
for a t4 anywhere on the planet right
now but point taken the open models can
be significantly cheaper and the blog
post explores the results from the paper
itself also a bit more again pointing
out that the advantages aren't that much
sometimes something like 0.1 f1 score
and oftentimes even behind the open
models another point he makes is that
the high dimensionality of the
embeddings might actually work against
you if you're looking to implement
anything because higher dimensional
vectors if you want to build a search
index for example they require a much
more memory intensive index structure
which will cost you more money and even
disregarding money searching through a
higher dimensional space can be a lot
slower than searching through a low
dimensional space and he points out that
is not really an option to compress
these high dimensional embeddings they
are using something like pca as that
deteriorates their performance quite
quickly now the claim is just made right
here but i think he must have some
experience or references from somewhere
so i guess that would also account for
down sampling methods such as random
projections but i don't know i guess
that's still open out there to try now
it is to be said that when the author
here tried to use the open ai api to
reproduce the numbers in the paper it
resulted in different numbers which
makes one wonder uh did they change the
model since the paper or maybe is there
something wrong with this evaluation now
curiously if i read this correctly
actually the numbers of the current api
used are better than the numbers that
are in the paper which is weird but also
people have pointed out minor issues
that can creep in and really destroy
your results such as guern right here
pointing out that you cannot have new
lines in your embedding queries
otherwise the embeddings become almost
unusable which is a thing that openai
discusses in their api documentation
however reimers responded to this and
said that yes indeed he had replaced the
new lines it actually used the exact
code that he found in an open ai website
snippet so these results do look pretty
legit in fact one of the main authors of
the paper has put out a response i guess
i mean it's not responding to anything
it's just a twitter thread but it comes
kind of in the light of these criticisms
about how they evaluate their embedding
models in open ai's api this goes into
more detail on the evaluation
mainly reciting points from the paper
but being a little bit more yeah we
don't always achieve the best results
possible uh than the the blog post is
because the blog post just shows average
numbers and says well we're
state-of-the-art pretty much everywhere
but if you look into detail a little bit
more uh the picture becomes a bit more
murky i'll link all the threads here in
the description i think one point to be
mentioned right here which is made by
the author here and also by the blog
post is that hello this is janik from
the future i've waited on this story a
bit because we have some new development
the authors quasi responded again and
not really brought anything new to the
table but just put sort of the things
being said into context here in that
they do point out that on many of the
information retrieval so the search
tasks uh the embeddings are actually
performing really well and that on on
zero shot keep that in mind including
for example the phi qa data set where
they outperform something like bm25 or
other models by a wide margin on top of
that they also put the cost in
perspective saying that for this example
data set and this is a fairly let's say
average data set the cost of embedding
the documents and the queries is eighty
dollars so the blog post always compared
costs of embedding x many millions of
tokens but if you go to actual data set
yes the embeddings are still going to be
more expensive but the absolute cost
might actually not be as much as the
blog post might seem of course that
depends entirely on how large your data
set is but spending 80 bucks for a 62
relative improvement seems to be a nice
deal so it seems to really depend on the
data set at hand and you might have to
try it out on a subset of your data this
was then greeted by a response response
saying that
yes but the much smaller model and much
cheaper model is just point one of a
score better than the largest gpt3 model
also niels asked why the evaluation was
just done on 11 out of the 18 data sets
we don't have a response yet to that but
it's been a week so i don't expect we'll
get one and that is where it stands
currently back to yannick in the past in
their experience these embeddings seem
to do quite well when you have to
transfer them to a new domain a lot of
these openly available models they are
trained on specific data sets you know
with specific benchmarks in mind and all
of that so they kind of come from the
academic world for the academic world
and therefore might over perform even on
a different data set it is still a clean
data set that has been assembled kind of
to be a benchmark and so on well what
openai is saying that if we take these
embeddings and actually go to the real
world our customers see big improvements
in their own applications now of course
there's no way to verify that and the
blog post lists three examples of
customers saying oh look they are able
to find like six to ten times more
relevant examples for something or they
pump their performance from 64 to 89
again there's no way to verify that but
i wouldn't actually be surprised if that
is the case real world data is a lot
more messy than any of the academic data
sets and therefore i guess only trying
it out will actually tell you whether
it's useful or not i do have to wonder
about the price though like there are
two possibilities essentially one opener
has done market research and so on and
this is what they think people will pay
for this like this is how much value
they think they bring with their api or
on the other hand this is kind of their
operating cost plus some margin to make
the shareholders happy now i really
can't tell apparently they do have
customers so someone must be willing to
pay all of this on the other hand it
does seem outrageously expensive for
such a small improvement at least in
these academic data sets so let me know
what you think is this even profitable
for openai like does anyone have any
estimates on what it costs them to
develop these new models and to keep
them running it must be massive
endeavour in any case that was it for
the special episode of ml news
merch is still available
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you